안녕하세요, 여러분 모두 환영합니다. 오늘 다들 어떠신가요? 이번 수업은
정말 멋진 듣기 말하기 수업이 될 겁니다. 여러분 모두 여기 와주셔서 정말 기쁩니다. 모두
환영합니다. 마치 근육을 단련하는 것과 같아요. 뇌는 근육이 아니지만 우리는 연결을
만들어냅니다. 우리는 더 강력한 연결을 만들죠. 그래서 오늘 우리의 목표는 여러분의 답변이
자연스럽고, 유창하며, 명확하도록 노력하는 것입니다. 제가 여러분이 말하는 동안
타이핑하는 것을 눈치채셨을 수도 있습니다. 제가 만들고 있는 이 수정 사항들 중 일부를 살펴보세요.
어떤 것들은 여러분이 조금 더 잘 말할 수 있는 표현으로 단순히 바꿔 말한 것입니다.
이것이 여러분의 유창성을 향상시킬 겁니다. 하지만 이것이 여러분의 말하기를 방해하지는 않았으면 합니다.
그저 자연스럽고, 유창하며, 명확하게 말하는 데 집중하도록 노력하세요. 전체 목표는
이해하고 이해받는 것입니다. 여기 질문이 있습니다. 영어를 말할 때 이미
자신 있다고 느끼는 한 가지는 무엇인가요? 모르겠어요. 어려운 질문이네요. 네, 그래서 제 생각엔
지금 영어를 말할 때, 누가 저를 수정해줘도
부끄럽다고 느끼지 않는 것 같아요. 그래서 그게 지금 제가 자신 있다고 느끼는 부분인 것 같습니다.
그건 정말 경험에서 나오는 거죠. 그게 도움이 됩니다. 다음 질문입니다. 영어 면접에서
어떤 부분이 어려울 것 같고, 그 이유는 무엇인가요? 제 생각엔
새로운 어휘가 될 것 같고, 또 표현해야 하거나 선생님께서 언급하신 것처럼
제가 생각하는 것을 좀 더 명확하고 간결하게 정리하려고 노력하는 것이요.
간결하게요. 네. 알겠습니다. 무언가를 명확하고 간결하게 말하려고 노력하는 것이죠.
네. 동의합니다. 이 모든 것들도 더 많이 할수록 향상될 수 있습니다. 그래서 우리는
오늘 수업에서 우리가 말하는 방식을 개선하여 더 명확하거나 간결하게 만들도록 노력할 수 있습니다.
그들이 묻는 가장 인기 있는 면접 질문 중 하나는
"자신에 대해 말해주세요"입니다. 그들은 여러분이 마음을 열기를 원합니다. 그들은 여러분이 어색함을 깨기를 원합니다.
그들은 이 질문을 백만 번은 물어봤을 겁니다. 어떤 사람들은 이것을 상대방에게
깊은 인상을 주거나, 제가 말했듯이, 어색함을 깨기 위해 사용합니다. 그들이 정말로 원하는 것은 무엇일까요?
그들이 정말로 원하는 것은 간결한 무언가입니다, 그렇죠? 1분에서 2분 정도요. 여러분의 전문적인 배경,
기술, 경력 목표에 대한 관련성 있는 요약, 이러한
그들이 알아야 할 필수적인 것들입니다. 왜냐고요? 만약 이것이 첫 번째 질문이라면,
그들은 여러분에 대해 매우 좋은, 매우 강력하고 긍정적인 첫인상을 가져야 하기 때문입니다.
그들이 묻는 첫 번째 질문에 대해서요. 여기 여러분의 꿈의 직업에 대한 활동이 있습니다. "자신에 대해
말해주세요" 답변에서 강조하고 싶은 한두 가지 주요 성과나 기술은 무엇인가요?
강조하고 싶은 두 가지 기술이나 성과는 무엇인가요? 제 생각엔
의사 결정과 관련된 것일 것 같습니다. 그리고 다른 하나는
음, 어떻게 말해야 할지 모르겠는데, 혼자서 무언가를 배울 때와 같은 것입니다.
그러니까 한 가지 기술은 의사 결정을 잘한다는 것이고, 또 다른 하나는
자기 자신에 대해 많이 안다는 것이군요. 다른 하나는 만약
제가 무언가를 모르면, 알 때까지 찾아본다는 것입니다. 알겠습니다. 그리고 저는
스스로 배우려고 노력합니다, 도움을 요청하기 전에요. 스스로 배우는군요. 네, 그러니까 도움을 요청하기 전에
스스로 배운다는 거죠. 그럼 스스로를 자율적인 사람이라고 생각하시는군요.
혼자서 자율적으로 일할 수 있다는 말씀이시죠. 맞나요? 네, 저는
둘 다 할 수 있지만, 네, 먼저 스스로 찾아보려고 노력합니다. 그리고 제 생각에 이것은
여러분이 좋은 결정을 내릴 수 있다는 사실을 강조할 것입니다. 그들이 여러분이 하는 일을
일일이 간섭할 필요가 없을 것이라는 점, 여러분이 올바른 답을 찾을 수 있다고 믿는다는 점,
여러분이 그들에게 부담이 되지 않을 것이라는 점, 그리고 여러분이 필요한 기술을 가지고 있다는 점을요.
제 생각에 그것이 좋은 첫인상을 주는 좋은 방법인 것 같습니다.
네, 그렇습니다. 그래서 이 질문에 답하는 데 사용할 수 있는 몇 가지 다른 표현들이 있습니다.
예를 들어, 만약 제가 누군가에게 제 자신에 대해 말한다면, 저는 제 이름은 데이비드 브라운이라고 말할 겁니다.
저는 제2외국어로서의 영어 교육에 열정적입니다.
저는 전 세계 학생들과 약 24,000번의 온라인 수업을 진행했습니다.
저는 중학교와 고등학교의 어린 학생들을 가르쳤고,
제가 하는 일에 정말로 동질감을 느낍니다. 제 자유 시간에도 그것에 대해 생각합니다.
저는 가족 및 친구들과 시간을 보내는 것을 좋아하고 새로운 기술에 대해
꿈꿉니다. 모르겠네요. 제가 곧 취업 면접이 있을지도 모르는데, 그게 제가 할 말일 겁니다.
노르마 학생, 말해주세요, 그것이 좋은 첫인상을 줄 것이라고 생각하나요?
네. 아, 그랬으면 좋겠네요. 이 수업이 저에게 더 좋은 건지 아니면 학생에게 더 좋은 건지 모르겠어요,
사실은요. 감사합니다. 감사합니다. 노르마 학생, 이 수업은 무료입니다. 자, 그럼 무엇이
그 예시를 이해하기 쉽게 만들었을까요? 제가 말을 좀 빨리 한 것 같기도 한데, 어떻게
생각하세요? 무엇이 그 예시를 이해하기 쉽게 만들었나요? 아니요, 사실 제가
들은 것은 선생님께서 가지신 경험에 관한 것이었습니다.
그리고 또한 선생님께서 함께 일하실 수 있는 연령대의 범위도 알 수 있었습니다. 그래서
선생님께서 나이가 많거나 어린 사람들과도 일하실 수 있다는 것을 알아요. 그리고 또한 선생님께서
가족을 돌보는 분이라는 것도요. 네, 또한, 네, 이미 좋은 듣기 능력을 가지고 계시네요.
제가, "what I listen*"이라고 말하는 대신, "what I, what I heard"라고 말할 수 있습니다.
오히려, "제가 들은 것은 선생님께서 가지신 경험에 관한 것이었고,
또한 선생님께서 일하실 수 있는 연령대도 알 수 있었습니다. 그래서 선생님께서 더 어리거나
나이 많은 사람들과도 일하실 수 있다는 것을 알아요."라고 말할 수 있습니다. 저는 완벽하게 이해했습니다. 자, 그럼 우리에게는 또한
이 다른 정말 큰 질문이 있습니다. 항상 묻는 질문이죠, "당신의 강점은 무엇인가요?"라고 물을 때요.
우리는 빛날 기회가 있습니다. 우리는 다른 사람들에게 우리가 가진 것을 보여줄 수 있습니다.
노르마 학생의 강점은 무엇인가요? 그래서 여러분은, 하지만 무엇을, 하지만 이것에 대해 구체적이어야 합니다, 그렇죠?
왜냐하면 우리는, 우리는 누군가에게 우리가 좋은 경청자라고 말할 수 있지만,
언제 좋은 경청자였나요? 그리고 어떤 상황에서 더 구체적으로 말할 수 있나요?
이것이 정말 도움이 될 수 있습니다. 만약 여러분이 구체적인, 구체적인 예를
제시할 수 있다면요. 그리고 나서 "당신의 가장 큰 약점은 무엇인가요?"라는 질문을 받으면, 여러분은
적극적으로 개선하고 있는 사소한 실제 약점을 선택할 수 있습니다. 이것은 여러분이
정직하다는 것을 보여줍니다. 그리고 그들은 "저는 완벽주의자예요"와 같은 진부한 표현은
피해야 한다고 말합니다, 여러분이 그것을 일반적으로 뒷받침할 수 없다면 말이죠. 여러분은 정말 완벽주의자인가요?